Hi, I'm Geoff Donaker. I live here in the Bay Area,
California Bay Area, and I have red and green color blindness.
>> Okay, so red green color blindness. We you know, just
sort of heard about that for the first time in the course, and
we're learning a bit more about the inheritance patterns. What is
red green colorblindness? What does it mean to be red green colorblind?
>> Well, to me, what it means is that I often mix
up colors that have red in them. And so, in particular I
mix up reds and browns and sometimes browns and greens because I'm not
seeing the red correctly in those. Sometimes it can even show up in the
form of blues and purples. I'm sort of seeing them all as about
the same and in fact, you know, they may look different to other people.
>> When did you first know that you had red-green colorblindness?
Yeah, I don't really remember. It was when I was really
young child. my uncle had been red-green color blind, and then
actually my mom's uncle as well. So I think I inherited
it from her side. And so when I was a little kid she recognized
that I might be color blind or had this propensity. And so she had
me tested at, you know, one of the eye doctors, with looking at those
little bubble charts with colors that you
may remember having taken at some point.
>> So you were very young when your, I guess, your mother found this out.
>> That's right.
>> And did it I mean, was it a, did it cause any
issue? I mean, was it like, okay, we knew this was a possibility and
now, what kind of, if anything, was there to do at that point?
>> Not really much. you know, as I say, her
brother and uncle had had it, and so she was
sort of aware of it. And, you know, it's useful
to know that you see the world in different colors than
everybody else just so you can be prepared. and, you
know, obviously that's something that I just am aware of today
too. So that I I don't say, you know, this
is definitely purple to other people if they, if I realize,
I go oh, it might actually be blue, and you know others are saying it's blue.
>> How do people respond to
this particular trait of red-green color blindness?
>> I'd say that you know probably about half of people that I interact
with already know somebody closely who is red-green color blind, so it's no news
to them. And they'll just say, oh yeah, my brother is also, or something
of that nature. And then the other half, it's a like a great party trick.
So the first time they hear that you're red-green color
blind, what they want to do is walk around the room going
What color's this? What color's this? What color's this? What color's?
You know, which is fun for about 30 seconds or so.
[LAUGH]
Then you're kind of ready to move on.
But that's been my general experience over the years.